à paris le marathon des collections de
mode a commencé hier et il va se
poursuivre jusqu'à jeudi
si sa vie présentation par jour une
vingtaine de couturiers 1500 modèles et
des centaines de journalistes venus du
monde entier
parmi ces privilégiés hélène et reliques
stein qui nous disent ce que seront les
tendances pour cet automne
et pour cet hiver hanae mori torrent
nina ricci ont ouvert le feu des grandes
collections automne hiver
mais tout d'abord vonthron dans les
coulisses de la mode coulisses où règne
une certaine fébrilité pour les
mannequins maquillage coiffure et c'est
pour les créateurs petits détails
accessoires touche finale enfin ça y est
tout est vérifié tout est contrôlé ces
trois grands sont prêts ils vous
présentent la haute couture française
une collection ces minis tres féminin la
taille est bien prise le décolleté large
la jambe est longue et le genou le plus
souvent visibles
côté style il est simple par sa ligne et
sophistiqué par ses accessoires comme
ici lien turban de saison les rares on
redevienne star et cela au détriment des
pantalons très discret cette année et
pantalon mais revenons au modèle man and
i'm really le tailleur et voit en crêpe
velours noir et rouge veste ajustée
boléro ensemble souple avec cap mouvante
robes en satin et mousseline fond noir
branches et de feuilles de rente
construction plus rigoureuse épaules
carrées manche travail et vestes aux
épaules larges triomphe des écossais
d'ailleurs prince de galles nina ricci
tout en noir et paillettes doublé
fourrure pour la nuit
robes en soie de velours très près du
corps voici les poufs ou robes drapées
avec bolland d'autruche étape cap lycée
pour le cocktail robes moulantes aux
couleurs vives
reconnaissez quand même que si la mode
était le seul critère d'une civilisation
la nôtre cette année serait bien belle